Speaker 1: You know, we often say when it
comes to faith healing, I'll be impressed
when they can actually regrow someone's amputated
limb.
Of course, it never happens.
We now have a woman claiming that indeed,
three amputated toes were regrown.
Now there is no evidence her toes were amputated.
There is no evidence that anything grew back.
They're not providing any such evidence.
But here she is.
She attends James River Church in Missouri.
She claims prayer regrew three toes.
It's a miracle.
Speaker 4: So it had three toes that were
amputated in in a terrible accident.
I heard the word for creative miracles.
And I thought, well, I certainly have a creative
miracle that I might need.
I need three toes to grow back.
The person next to me said, Do you want your
toes?
And I was like, Well, sure.
All the women got down and they prayed over
my foot and I decided to take my shoe off
to see what was happening.
When he said, Let's see the progress or if
anything happened.
And when I did, I had to grab the person next
to me and say, Do you see what I see?
And I saw three toes that were forming and
now there's links to them.
Tonight I can stand on my kidney.
Go right.
Do you understand?
I can stand on tippy toes.
No, I couldn't do that because I didn't it.
Be on.
Speaker 1: It's pretty remarkable stuff, folks.
And obviously, they're presenting no evidence
whatsoever.
Here's Pastor John Lindell of the church who
says he has the proof, but he is not going
to share it with the people demanding the
proof because they're not in favor of what
he's doing.
It's not up to him to validate this stuff.
Speaker 2: As you know, there's been quite
a furor.
Speaker 1: I like that a furor on.
Speaker 2: Social media relative to the girl
with the toes.
Yeah, because her miracle Israel, it's genuine.
People are saying, well, if it's genuine,
why aren't you Why aren't you doing anything
with it to publicize it?
There's a couple of reasons I want to say
to you.
First of all, I'm less interested in proving
to people what I know God did than I am in
protecting sheep who are vulnerable right
now.
Speaker 1: Of course.
This is total B.S. and this is where it really
becomes B.S.
He says he's not interested in proving it
to people.
The whole point of evangelical Christianity
is to proselytize.
It's to evangelize.
It's to bring people in.
This is the greatest thing they can do.
It's the greatest mitzvah.
And of course, I'm using the term mitzvah.
Tongue in cheek, because they're evangelical
Christians.
So why would I use the term mitzvah?
I understand it's the greatest thing you could
do.
The whole point of these religions is to perpetuate
themselves by getting people to convert.
What would more powerfully get people to convert?
Then proving that you regrew three amputated
toes for a comparison.
I know I've said explain this to people before.
Jus which is the culture.
I'm from Judaism.
There's no proselytizing.
We're not looking to add people to the ranks.
Even if someone wants to convert, they're
dissuaded multiple times and it's a very difficult
process.
So this is a religion that is all about that.
Their main point is to spread the gospel,
and he has the most powerful tool to do that.
That prayer regrew the three toes of a woman
whose toes had been amputated.
But he's not going to do it.
He's not going to do it.
It's a missed opportunity, my friend.
Obviously, it is complete and total nonsense.
We don't even know whether this woman's toes
were ever amputated.
There's no evidence they grew back.
There was no evidence of anything.
But that is not a big shock to those of us
that have been following the faith healing
movement for a very long time.